ces lignes d'eau seront bientôt vide ces
élèves sont les derniers à profiter de
ces installations
à la fin de la semaine le grand chalet
fermera définitivement ses portes
le collège du russe et qui organise ici
depuis vingt ans un séjour natation
d'une semaine devra désormais faire sans
sans cette structure on serait obligé de
repasser à des séances hebdomadaires aux
puces sim de mèche aux fins qui sont
beaucoup moins rentable au niveau
apprentissage ou alors cherche
éventuellement des structures plus
plus éloignés qu'ils seront plus
coûteuses plus coûteuses et peut-être
moins bien on n'en trouve pas quoi à
mouthe c'est pourtant une institution
classe de neige classe verte colonie de
vacances gérée par la pep l'association
des pupilles de l'enseignement public
depuis 1976 des milliers d'enfants ont
construit ici des souvenirs cet hiver
encore l'établissement affichait complet
aujourd'hui l'équipe qui devrait faire
les plannings doit se résoudre à
inventorier les stocks
un crève coeur on est on est
on est déçu on se dit que c'est la
dernière fois qu'on accueille des
enfants dernière fois qu'on dit au
revoir aux russes
c'est oui c'est un peu compliqué de
gestion faute d'entretien ces dernières
années le bâtiment se dégradent défaut
de sécurité infiltration il faudrait
près de trois millions d'euros pour le
mettre aux normes la dans des endroits
les plus visités de franche comté la
source du doubs attire énormément de
monde
et puis pour ces enfants qui viennent
régulièrement en centre de vacances et
puis en classe on a besoin de ce site
dans les cartons depuis deux ans le
projet d'un nouveau bâtiment se fait
attendre
ils nous ont annoncé un nouveau projet
pour la fin de l'année et je pense que
et la communauté de communes et et la
commune nous ferons tous effectivement
pour encourager sa réalisation
les classes de neige assure 30%
d'activité à l'école de ski la fermeture
d'un tel site aurait de graves
conséquences pour le massif